Salut, aujourd'hui je suis avec Lola Dubiniiiii !!!
Lola : L'intro sous LSD
Comme j'ai eu la chance de la rencontrer sur un plateau, on a fait un plateau ensemble pour "Mademoiselle".
Lola : Exactement !
Et ça c'était juste formidable de se rencontrer...
Lola : Qu'il est gentil !
On est sur un lit tu le sais *rires*
MENTALISATION !
Il y a quelques temps, je vous ai fait la vidéo numéro 2 sur le cold reading
Et on a beaucoup discuté ensemble dans les commentaires
du fait que effectivement il fallait pas se fier à une seule chose.
Il fallait prendre en compte une base line.
pour interpréter les choses.
C'est à dire que ce n'est pas une poignet de main qui va nous dire qui est la personne.
Il faut prendre en compte tout le contexte.
Qui est la personne ?
Comment elle est ? etc...
Et je me suis aperçu qu'on retrouvait ça aussi
dans pleins d'autres domaines, y compris dans la musique.
Petit lien avec Lola Dubini !
Puisqu'en parlant avec Lola,
on s'est marrés sur un truc.
Avec quatre accords, on pouvait avoir pleins d'interprétations possibles.
Pleins de chansons possibles
Vrai ou faux?
Lola : Vrai ! On peut avoir pleins d'interprétations et d'interprètes.
Est-ce que tu pourrais nous prouver ça?
Lola : Oui
Et est-ce que tu pourrais en même temps,
pour moi et pour ceux qui regardent la chaîne,
m'apprendre à jouer les accords?
Lola : Bien évidemment !
Lola : Ça c'est... J'allais dire, tout comme tu mentalises les gens, je peux te montrer, je peux te mentaliser sur la musique
Mes doigts !
Lola : Oui mentaliser tes doigts, plutôt !
Puisque ça, j'vous l'ai pas dis, mais c'est ouf je vous mettrais un lien, à la fin on en reparlera
Mais Lola, elle a une chaîne qui est vraiment fun,
vraiment cool,
et en même temps tu donnes des conseils sur la musique
et tu nous apprends des trucs à la guitare.
Lola : J'essaye !
Et des trucs qu'on avaient pas appris encore..
Lola : Ahhhhh !
Et ouais, j'avais jamais vu ça !
Non, bon bref ! On vous en reparle à la fin, mais voilà, elle transmet son savoir
Lola : Alors, euh.
Tu m'as prévu une gratte? c'est ça
Bah prends la petite
Mais je suis trop mignon avec cette petite guitare.
Lola : Ouai !
Lola : 4 Accords qu'on va pouvoir tourner en boucle
Lola : Ce qui va vraiment changer, ça va être la manière dont on va les jouer.
Donc, la manière, j'entends pas les accords,
mais j'entends plutôt le rythme.
D'accord !
Lola : C'est-à-dire qu'en fonction des rythmes,
tu vas pouvoir retrouver l'interprétation originale.
Donc le premier accord, c'est un MI.
Alors, tu places tes deux doigts sur la deuxième case
1ère corde à vide, 2ème corde/2ème case, 3ème corde/3ème case, et le reste à vide
Après on passe sur un DO.
2ème corde/3ème case, 3ème corde/2ème case, 4ème corde à vide, 5ème/1ère case, et 6ème à vide
Donc c'est MI
DO
SOL
SOL, je sais le faire !
Je sais le faire le SOL.
Je vous le fais voir.
1ère corde/3ème Case, 2ème corde/2ème case, vide, vide, vide, et 6ème corde/3ème case
Lola : Et après on passe sur un RE.
D'accord, le petit triangle !
Lola : Voilà le triangle !
MI
DO
SOL
RÉ
Lola : Voilà.
Lola : Avec ses 4 accords là,
on peut avoir pleins de chansons possibles et inimaginables.
Et c'est surtout, il y en a qui vont dire "Ouais mais c'est pas exactement les vrais accords".
Alors oui et non.
En fait c'est juste que ces accords là ensemble font le ...
Nous donne l'impression que c'est la même chanson.
C'est ce que je sais faire de mieux à la guitare :
*guitare*
Lola : Est-ce que tu as des idées de chansons ?
Ah oui, putain, faut que je cherche !
Moi j'en ai et c'est pour ça que j'trouve ça sympa si d'ailleurs si vous en avez en commentaires qu'on a pas
Ah oui rajoutez les rajoutez les en commentaires !
Lola : Alors la 1ère,
Lola: ça va pas être dans le rythme que l'on fait.
Lola: C'est qu'on va faire un rythme un peu plus rock.
Lola: Donc on va prendre la paume de sa main et on va la... voilà comme ça
pour donner un effet feutré
donc là on est un peu plus sur du Rock
Sens le feutre Youtube
*Cramberries - Zombies*
Another head hangs lowly
Child is slowly taken
And the violence caused such silence
Who are we mistaken
But You see it's not me,
It s not my family
In your head, in your head
Head they are fighting
In your head,
In your head
Zombie Zombie Zombiie
Donc voilà ça c'est la première
Voilà pourquoi j'ai voulu faire cette vidéo avec Lola, c'est juste pour vivre moi ce moment là avec elle
Lola: Cranberries Zombie donc là on l'a joué d'une manière un peu feutré très calme
et là on va jouer une autre chanson qui n'a strictement rien à voir
donc là je vous donne les chansons qui ont le plus... enfin le moins à voir ensemble
les plus gros parallèles
Khaled "Aïcha"
Comme si, j'n'existais pas
Elle est passée à côté de moi
Sans un regard, reine de Saba
J'ai dis Aïcha, prend tout est pour moi
IN YOUR HEAD ! IN YOUR HEAD
ZOMBIE ZOMBIE ZOMBIE
Lola: Tu vois ces 2 chansons là n'ont rien à voir
Ah c'est drôle
Lola: et pourtant tu peux les mettre ensemble
ce qui donne d'ailleurs souvent, on a eu une mode, tu sais
Tu connais la série Glee?
Fabien: Ah je crois que j'en ai trouvé une. Oui
Lola: tu connais la série Glee
Fabien: Oui
Lola: Et bien ils ont amené un peu dans l'air du temps ce qu'on appelle des mash up
Lola: Et les medley
C'est vraiment eux qui ont ramené ça dans la culture... dans la culture courante
et... c'est donc assez récent au final
et c'est pour ça que tu vois maintenant beaucoup de vidéos avec des medley c'est entre autre grâce à Glee
donc euh voilà
Lola: Tu en a trouvé alors?
Fabien: J'en ai trouvé une
Lola: Vas y je t'en prie
Fabien: Un truc bien récent. Ah oui par contre faut que je chante pour le dire
Lola: elle s'appelle comment la chanson?
Fabien: Terrible, je sais même pas
*guitare* Fabien: *rire* J'allais chanter Aïcha
Ne l'a laisse pas tombé, elle est si fragile
être une femme libérée, tu sais c'est pas si facile
Ne la laisse pas tomber
Fabien: J'en ai trouvé une c'est oufff
Lola: Donc là on est quand même sur des chansons qui sont dans un style complètement différent
Fabien: Wouah c'est dingue
Lola: qui n'ont pas du tout les mêmes interprètes et qui font parti de 3 cultures qui sont complètement différentes
C'est ça le fait que tu es commencé par Cranberries
Ben là Cranberries c'est vraiment du vieux rock, groupe hyper mythique
On passe sur Khaled qui à part Aïcha ben voilà il a fait c'est la vie lala lala
Voilà *rire*
et ... du coup sur Cookie Dingler avec ne la laisse pas tomber année 80
Ouais j'en ai pleins tu peux faire
Je veux juste une dernière danse
Avant l'ombre et l'indifférence
Un vertige puis le silence
Je veux juste une dernière danse
Belle demoiselle
Qui se presse dans l'allée
Ouais c'était Kyo et là c'est Christophe Maé
Sa démarche lui donne des ailes
Mais j'ose pas m'emballer
et généralement, on a beaucoup critiquer Christophe Maé
Parce que je sais pas si tu as entendu un petit peu cette affaire c'est Mickaël Grégorio
Qui est un imitateur et humoriste
Qui a fait un super spectacle
en fait il a fait pendant 3 minutes un medley donc de toutes les chansons de Christophe Maé sur les même accords
Fabien: Ah c'est drôle
Lola: Qui d'ailleurs doit être ceux que je suis en train de vous donnez là
Lola: "Alors c'est pas du tout du plagiat mais"
F: "Je peux jouer tout Christophe Maé?"
Lola: "Tu peux jouer beaucoup de chansons de Christophe Maé parce que c'est... je te dis c'est tout dans la même veine
Chant: *Papa tu as pris la route sans dire adieu*
*Papa*
*tu as laissé na na , je t'en veux*
*ça fait mal de vivre sans toi*
Lola: Ooouuuhhh
F: "J'ai juste passé une note là"
L: "On est sur du Carlos Santana là...  quand même. Voilà, on peut souligner
L: "Donc voilà tu peux..."
F: "Faire pleurer les guitares moi sinon"
L: "Tu peux même faire..."
F: "Moi je fais pas pleurer les guitares je fais pleurer les viewer"
*rire*
L: "Moi j'ai une vraie question. Est ce que tu te souviens de cette chanson car je suis à peu près la seule en m'en souvenir à chaque fois que je la joue
L: "ça fait:"
*Petite conne... ta na na Petite conne*
F: Qui chantait ça?
L: *ta nanana*
L: "Je me souviens plus du tout mais c'était"
*Petite nanana tananana, petite c**** *
L: "C'était à la même époque que 'Au nom de la Rose' là"
F: "Ah oui"
L: "Et tu peux faire du Rap... tu peux faire plein de truc"
L: *Où t'était? invité par des potes à une teufé, on s'amusait bien j'ai pas vu l'heure qu'il était*
*ah ouais c'est vrai, je te connais par cœur*
F: "Pourquoi je fais la femme"
*rires*
*rire*
L: "J'avoue, j'avoue"
F: "Spontanément j'ai pris la meuf dans la chanson"
L: "Parce que les parties de la meuf c'est les parties où tu as le plus envie de chanter quoi"
L: *Ah ouais c'est vrai... mmmm, je te connais par coeur* c'est là où tu as le plus envie de donner de toi"
F "Si vous voulez mettre à la guitare je trouve que c'est une super motivation...
L: "Exact"
F: "de se dire je commence par apprendre quelques accords et je peux jouer pleins de chansons avec"
L: "C'est d'ailleurs les 4 accords les plus simples à réaliser à la guitare
parce que... ils vont pouvoir si vous êtes autour du feu...
avec vos potes, ben c'est les accords où vous allez pouvoir"
F: "Avec les manifs"
L: "Tout chanter"
L: "Voilà avec les manifs en ce moment"
L:" donc si vous êtes au milieu d'une rue avec des pneus qui brûlent"
F: "qui brulent; Sortez une guitare"
L: "N'hésitez pas à sortir une guitare"
F: "Où appelez Lola Dubini"
L: "Non pas pour alimenter le feu mais pour alimenter les chants"
L: "Tu peux en faire pleins, tu peux en créer... à la guise"
F: "C'est drôle, tu vois j'ai même pas pensé à ça pour la vidéo mais c'est vrai, c'est hyper motivant je trouve pour vous.
F: "Pour que vous puissiez apprendre 4 accords"
F: " et de se dire... ben..."
L: "Ben ouais ouais"
F: "Je regarde la vidéo avec Lola et ça me donne pleins d'idées de chansons déjà que je peux faire"
L: "Ben en fait, moi c'est comme ça que j'ai commencé la guitare, c'est en... "
Enfin si vous avez envie de commencer la guitare, prenez des chansons qui vous font kiffer et qui sont atteignable"
"donc par exemple ses 4 accords là"
"vous avez tellement de chansons possible que vous êtes sûr de trouver votre compte"
"et d'être motiver et du coup de trouver des motivations"
et dans le même style tu as des accords, tu vois genre LA mineur
FA
DO
SOL
c'est des accords hyper simple à part le FA qui est en barré mais que tu peux aussi faire
tu peux aussi faire en accord, j'allais dire plus basique
tu peux trouver :
*Oh won't you stay with me*
*Cause you're all I need*
*This ain't love it's clear to see*
*But darling stay with me*
F: [chuchote] "j''ai rajouté mon petit doigt"
L: "En fait c'est accord là, si tu les fais peut être dans un ordre différent"
F: "Oui c'est ça en plus c'est que là pour l'instant tu as fait dans le même ordre mais si en plus on les redéplaçais dans un autre ordre
L: "Sur les accords que je viens de te montrer là..."
*I won't you stay with me*
LA
FA
DO
SOL
L: "Tu peux faire en changeant l'ordre. Tu peux faire"
*Jimmy won't you please come home
Where the grass is green and the buffaloes roam*
L: "c'est moi qui me suis trompée"
L: "Donc c'est Jimmy"
L: "Tu fais LA
DO
SOL
FA
L: "Donc t'as changé l'ordre"
L: "mais par contre c'est toujours les même accords"
F: "C'est fou"
F: "Et euh... concernant la voix?
L: "Ouais"
F: "Parce que... en fait j'ai pas été équipé"
L: "Ah tu as pas été de bonnes cordes vocales"
F: "Voilà, alors est ce que t'as... tu as quoi toi un auto-tune ici"
L: "Ouais effectivement j'ai acheté un pro tools *rire*
L: "J'ai acheté... une petite rallonge euh... à mes parents"
L: "Ils m'ont dis tiens Lola est ce que tu veux en bonus une voix?"
L: "Je me suis dis: 'peut être que ça peux me servir à parler' "
F: "Donc quand moi je suis à côté je pense que c'est fake"
*rire*
F: "Mais merci beaucoup Lola Dubini"
L: "mais de rien c'est avec plaisir, c'était des petits accords comme ça"
"jeter sur le vif. N'hésitez pas à... d'ailleurs vraiment si vous trouvez d'autres chansons, n'hésitez pas à nous en mettre il en existe des milliers"
"de possible avec ces 4 accords"
F: "Pour faire un vrai lien avec la chaîne parce que 'vous dites oui okay  ils nous as parlé au début de Cold reading"
"pour après faire de la musique avec Lola Dubini"
"pas tout à fait faux"
*rire*
F: "Mais c'est aussi pour moi une très très belle image pour vous dire
quand vous avez un signe d'interprétation pour du non verbal comme du cold reading
"ne vous fiez jamais à une seule chose. Parce qu'en fait elle peut être interpréter de 1000 manières différentes"
"et c'est ce qu'on a vu avec ces guitares là"
F: "Je trouve que  je suis un génie d'avoir penser à ce lien"
L: "Moi je trouve que ce lien... Fabien... me donne envie de chialer"
F: "c'est... c'est... ben moi j'ai chialé quand je l'ai écrit"
*rire*
F: "Mais des larmes de sang par contre"
L: "C'est ça j'entends mais ça c'est parce que tu avais chanté avant"
F: "Tout à fait, je me suis entendu en fait"
L: "En plus, je suis sur que tu mens et que tu chantes bien"
F: "Non mais je chante pas faux, je chante juste mais apparemment c'est très agaçant quand je chante"
L: "ah"
F: "Je pense que je mets beaucoup trop d'intentions..."
L: "mais tu sais... la plus... la plus mauvaise chanson chantée  avec la meilleure intention du monde c'est la plus belle des chansons"
F: "Ah c'est beau ce que tu dis"
F: "et c'est comme ça que nous allons nous marier avec Lola Dubini"
L: "Oui marions nous!!!"
F: "Merci d'être venu chez moi en ramenant ton lit, et ton décor"
L:"Et mes murs"
L: "Ben écoute c'est avec grand plaisir, c'est vrai que du coup il y a un camion qui m'attends en bas. D'ailleurs si vous entendez du bruit depuis tout à l'heure c'est qu'il klaxonne parce qu'il se fait emmerder"
F: "C'est ça et bien on va vite redescendre"
F: "Si vous ne connaissait pas la chaîne de Lola Dubini... et bien je ne vous plains pas au contraire je vous dis c'est cool"
"parce que vous allez pouvoir avoir le plaisir de la découvrir comme moi je l'ai déjà découvert"
"en cliquant sur le petit lien qui est... "
faut toujours inverser donc qui est ici"
"voilà là vous pouvez cliquer"
"et dans quelques secondes je vais mentaliser Lola"
L: "oui j'ai trop hâte"
F: "Mais je vais pas la mentaliser ici, je vais la mentaliser chez elle sur sa"
L: "sur ma chaine"
F: "oui sur ta chaîne, à toi directement"
L: "et je suis trop contente que tu viennes sur ma chaîne"
F: "Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo et si elle vous a plu n'hésitez pas à nous faire savoir en nous laissant à Lola et à moi"
F: "un petit léger mais forcément gracieux et mélodique"
F: "Pouce en l'air"
F: "vous pouvez nous laissez un commentaire évidemment je les lirai tous et je sélectionnerais les meilleurs pour les envoyer en texto à Lola''
L:"et puis moi j'irai les lire aussi surtout"
F: "mais bien sûr"
L: "J'irai les lire, j'irai répondre. Si vous avez des questions par rapport aux accords, les positions de doigts etc... "
L: "N'hésitez pas à les mettre en commentaire parce que j'aime bien aussi répondre"
F:"Ah moi aussi j'aime bien"
L: "moi j'adore"
F: "ah c'est cool"
F: "N'oubliez pas également de vous abonner à la chaîne avant de partir pourquoi"
Parce que le mentalvlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an donc rdv demain à 17h"
"ciao"
*In your head, in your head
Zombie, zombie*